chip and Joanna the now family up seven
is enjoying life away from the TV
spotlight as we go inside their life
after fixer-upper it's like the kids are
the most important thing to us so
anything that we do always go back to
that and say how is this gonna affect
our family unit our kids
the couple's number one priority says
the series finale in April family and
bonding with baby crew who arrived in
June it just felt right for us to take a
timeout
step back see if we couldn't catch our
breath and see what's next the life
hasn't exactly slowed down for the
parents of five since the cameras
stopped rolling at March they opened
their first restaurant Magnolia table
after almost two years of renovation all
I want to do is own a restaurant once
before I die
chip celebrated another milestone in May
he ran in his first marathon as for
Joanna well this month she just finished
her third book which is all about design
don't Joey the couple is still flipping
houses and running a real estate
business in their hometown of Waco Texas
Waco is also where their estimated 18
million dollar Magnolia Empire is
headquartered
Joanna shared this behind-the-scenes
look and how they're decorating Magnolia
market for fall it's amazing how fast
this process happens cuz we only really
have
hey guys we are done isn't it pretty
okay kiddos let's hit the sack mommy you
did great is always so proud of you I do
okay you kill the lights let's roll
so what the games ever consider
returning to TV and I think we have no
idea I think what we love about this is
we really don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]